you know things are bad for the
Democrats when their most prominent
Governor is joining us the conservatives
in predicting a red wave next Tuesday
does it feel like a Red Wave yeah of
course it does and and again uh I'm not
paid to say that I'm paid to say you
know we have a fate and feel I mean I
get it look I mean I could be the
cheerleader I'm also a pragmatist you
feel it
of course it does now do you ever listen
to Huey Lewis in the news Governor
Bateman he's he's right on this okay the
guy is a stone cold psychopath and he's
looking at the situation and he's saying
yeah of course it looks and feels and
seems like a Red Wave if water pipes
don't break in Georgia and ballots are
not submitted days after the election in
Philadelphia then it certainly does feel
like a Red Wave now Gavin Newsom has
something of an ulterior motive here for
pessimism he is the top Democrat
Prospect to replace Joe Biden in 2024 so
the the worst that Biden is perceived to
be governing the better things are for
Newsome but Newsom is not alone in
predicting this Red Wave on the Democrat
side and while Newsome seems rather
Placid about the whole situation the
other Democrats are not they are now
going on TV warning that a GOP went on
Tuesday will mean political violence the
end of democracy and even the wholesale
Slaughter of children
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Connor
schoenfeld who says Biden did not double
down on his Mega Maga threat to
democracy speech yesterday he just
forgot that he already gave the speech a
couple of weeks ago you make a good
point maybe it was not a double down the
staff probably thought of it as a double
down but Biden he probably just thought
wow I'm this is going to be the greatest
speech I've ever given did I tell you
the one did I tell you the one Jack
about how the Republicans are fascists
uh yes
I don't know Mr President tell me that
one but again well Jack you see I don't
know I want to before I make that point
I want to tell you did you know the
Republicans are fascists uh uh wow
really interesting point Joe Biden it's
just going to be on and on and on like
Groundhog Day now when you want to say
things that are interesting not really
silly platitude and his talking points
but things that are interesting and
matter when you want to tell those
things to your friends you got to check
out Pure Talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles Biden's
Administration has taken to Twitter to
assault shell and Exxon Mobil for
posting record profits unsurprisingly
however they've turned a blind eye to
every other industry what about the
billions of dollars made by big Pharma
big Tech even big wireless Verizon ATT
T-Mobile they all pushed billions in
profits every single quarter why doesn't
the administration call out those
massive companies when it comes to
buying gas you don't have many choices
sure you may have a couple of cents at
one gas station versus another but it's
a global commodity you do have choices
when it comes to choosing a Wireless
company that is why you need to check
out puretalk switching to Pure Talk can
save you 50 off your current bill every
single month you could be paying thirty
dollars per month for talk text and data
your family could be saving almost one
thousand dollars per year for the same
coverage for the same service you have
right now a veteran owned proudly
American company pure talk doesn't
overcharge their customers to keep their
shareholders is happy you can switch to
their service today in as little as 10
minutes go to puretalk.com enter code
Knowles to save 50 off your first month
that's puretalk.com promo code nulls for
50 off your first month the end of
democracy is upon us
and the Liberals are saying this is the
case not just because the politicians
are saying it but because even very
serious necktie wearing dark Blazer
having
presidential historians say so the man
who made this claim on TV is a guy named
Michael beschlas who is always billed as
presidential historian and he sort of is
but it's stretching it a little bit
Michael beschlas is not an academic
historian Michael besch laws is a guy
with a ba in Poli SCI from Williams who
then went to Harvard Business School and
he writes history so I'm not saying that
he's not an historian in any sense of
the word but you know the guy is not
Samuel Elliott Morrison okay the guy is
not not thucidities that we're talking
about really this guy's function in
public life is to go on liberal news
channels and whine about Republicans
that's that's his main activity the fact
that he writes books about the
presidents is it's a kind of tangential
actually to what he actually does in
public life but his utility for the libs
is that they can bring him on and they
can say he's a presidential historian
tell us presidential historian what you
think of the situation and always say
well from my very serious uh highly
credible position of authorities an
historian I want to tell you that the
Republicans are very bad and the
Democrats are very good and so that's
what he's doing now except they're
turning the rhetoric up to 11. and
bashless actually believes if the
Republicans win on Tuesday well I'll let
him tell you in his own words
well he was absolutely candid and he was
absolutely right because as you know
Chris six nights from now we could all
be discussing violence all over this
country there are signs that that may
happen May God forbid that uh losers
will be declared winners by fraudulent
election officers or Secretary of State
candidates or Governors or state
legislatures we could be six days away
from losing our rule of law and losing a
situation where we have elections that
we all can rely on you know those are
the foundation stones of a democracy a
historian 50 years from now if
historians are allowed to write in this
country and if there are still free
publishing houses in a free press which
I'm not certain of but if that is true a
historian will say what was at stake
tonight and this week was the fact
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed we're on
the edge of a brutal authoritarian
system and it could be a week away
tracking it I mean it's total hack
partisan nonsense but hey that's MSNBC
and that's what Michael beshwas does so
I was tracking it you know it's a threat
to democracy okay we've heard that
before
and and this was the moment the 2022
midterm elections
Congressional elections that that was
the point at which we lost the rule of
law
and the historians were all sent to the
gulag
and our children were arrested and
conceivably killed
what the hell are you talking about it's
it's even worse than what the hell are
you talking about it's even worse than
absurd because not only are the
Republicans not doing that
the Democrats are doing that and
actually campaigning on that
the Democrats
not only encouraged political violence
for the past three years not very high
level people bailing rioters out of the
BLM riots bailing the violent people out
encouraging people to illegally protest
outside of Supreme Court Justices houses
encouraging Democrats to push back on
Republicans in public and to go to their
homes where their children sleep
encouraging people Hillary Clinton said
don't be civil with Republicans you
can't be civil with them so not only
have the Democrats encouraged the
political violence
not only are the Democrats the ones
suppressing speech suppressing people
who make historical claims suppressing
people who descend from the current
ruling regime through the enforcement of
big Tech through monthly meetings from
the federal government that they control
to the allegedly private companies that
control the Public Square saying don't
let these people speak don't let the New
York Post run a story on Hunter Biden's
laptop don't let anyone question covet
don't let anybody question election
fraud don't let anybody do this not only
are they doing that they are explicitly
running on killing children this
election this one in particular the
Democrats because they were losers on
every single issue the economy
immigration foreign policy the list goes
on and on they chose to run primarily on
abortion
they actually they said okay the Dobb's
decision overrules Roe v Wade and so we
are going to stake our campaign
specifically on the alleged right to
kill babies
I know that when the Democrats make
accusations it's really projection and
it's really confession and we all know
that but what's amazing about Michael
beschlas maybe he really is a historian
maybe he really does have some academic
shops because it's what's amazing is the
absolute Precision of projection here
he is putting on the Republicans with no
evidence whatsoever the stuff that the
Democrats are campaigning on
the rule of law could be over bro you
guys were just campaigning on abolishing
the police okay and not enforcing some
of our most basic laws what are you
talking about and bailing criminals out
of prison which Kamala Harris did and
staffers for Biden did
the Republicans want to kill babies no
man that's we that's not only what you
you guys do that's that's your platform
and you and you see this now
you don't need to take my word for it I
mean you've all seen this obviously in
our culture for many years but even this
week even as the abortion issue has been
such a loser for Dems in the midterm
elections they're doubling down on it
this week on The View those sort of
cackling hens of the liberal
establishment came out and they're
they're Furious because the abortion
issue has not worked to bring the women
over to the Democrat Party they don't
change their views on it they don't have
any introspection they just attack the
women who are voting for Republicans as
cockroaches
I read a poll just yesterday that white
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right
now
Gilead okay so do we love it in the
hands do we love democracy or not
because just saying that it's it's
insulting to the voter people make up
decisions on what's right for their
family and the idea that well you should
have a say for everyone else's book the
fact that women are voting again you had
a different view on abortion not long
ago
but that issue is right but then why but
then why is another woman but I am
that white Republican Suburban Women
Health Care
that'll probably win them over don't you
think when when you have voters that
you're trying to court who reject you
and your platform the the way to win
them over is to insult them and call
them cockroaches and idiots right hey
idiot roaches
you got to vote for me dummies you dumb
disgusting people vote for me yeah okay
let's try that one until next Tuesday
please keep that going and it's so
offensive but you hear the you hear this
argument from Democrats all the time and
they apply it to black people and
Hispanics and all the rest they say
you're voting again and they apply to
the working class you're voting against
your own interest
and and they're so smug about it it's in
your interest to vote for us Democrats
because we'll give you money and we'll
let you kill your babies
did it ever occur to these women
to these Democrats broadly that maybe
mothers don't consider it in their
interest to kill their own children
did they have they ever considered that
maybe workers don't consider it in their
own interest to vote for a party that is
going to destroy the energy industry
potentially plunge the world into World
War III and cause record high inflation
which disproportionately affects the
poor did they ever consider that it
might not be in the interest of black
people to vote for a party that wants to
get rid of all the cops and and allow
neighborhoods that are already Rife with
crime to become even more criminal and
dangerous did it ever occur to them did
it ever occur to these people that may
be Hispanics in the United States
especially those who came here legally
don't think that it is their interest to
have a completely open border and fled
the country with foreign Nationals just
because they have roughly the same Hue
of skin as that that they do
did it ever no of course not they're
just so freaking smug they are
frequently wrong but they are never in
doubt and they are doubling down and
they are not going to give up their
narrative and it looks like it's going
to absolutely destroy them
on Tuesday hence Governor Bateman's
Governor newsom's prediction now
one thing that we are doing in this
culture and economy that is completely
opposed to us is we're building a
parallel economy so we don't need to
give our money to corporations that hate
our guts that's why you got to check out
Black Rifle coffee
right now head on over to Black Rifle
coffee use code Knolls while today's
coffee often comes with hints of soy and
social justice Black Rifle delivers an
entirely different experience
bold strong delicious Black Rifle coffee
is the coffee that gets me through my
day Black Rifle coffee company is
veteran founded and operated their
mission is to help service members
successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship they
provide assistance to Veterans who seek
to launch businesses of their own with
the goal of helping more companies like
Black Rifle become a reality Black Rifle
is committed to hiring 10 000 veterans
and they're well on their way as for the
coffee itself which is actually what I
care about even more than all the good
that the company does for veterans and
for the United States I really I'm very
particular about my coffee they're very
selective about where they Source their
coffee and beans and they're very
disciplined when it comes to ensuring
the freshness of every single bag go to
Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
Knowles for 10 off your first order or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that subscription gives you
free shipping on all coffee Club orders
Early Access to Club deals and
promotions and special discounts from
their partner Brands that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code novels for 10
off your first order or when you sign up
to become a coffee Club member Black
Rifle coffee supporting veterans and
America's coffee
I just saw the most nauseating news
story I have ever seen in my entire life
and it came out yesterday and you paid
for it actually
no you didn't pay for it with your daily
wire subscription you paid for it with
your tax dollars because it was on NPR
and I'm going to urge
listener discretion right now and viewer
discretion if if you have a weak stomach
just skip forward one minute right now
just one minute that's all it's really
going to take
because NPR aired
the audio of a woman's abortion NPR
aired
the the room with the doctors you know
with the abortionists and a mother
murdering her own child and
play the tape
she's from Michigan she already has one
kid she's having her abortion at about
11 weeks nearly all abortions in
Michigan are before 13 weeks put a pause
right there I just had well I didn't
just have my second child my wife had my
second child but you know it's a group
effort at least to some degree I
participated at least you know in the
very beginning and we would go to the
sonograms
11 weeks
not only do you know the sex of your
child not only are the basic features of
your child quite formed at that point 11
weeks that baby is a baby
that baby is moving around that baby is
recognizable as a baby 11 weeks is
is pretty far along
and so they're saying this this woman
who's already got one child out here in
the world
is going into this room
to murder her child who is 11 weeks who
is
you know that this baby is a baby
you know mothers and mothers know really
instantly but
and and you know that this mother knows
that this baby is a baby because the
mother is crying in the audio and it's
not tears of joy again if you've got a
weak stomach
just skip ahead one or two clicks right
now you'll move past the Audio I think
it's important to hear it though because
I think that this news story completely
backfired on NPR
unlike many patients at Northland she
said I could record her procedure we're
going to hear some of that now so I am
just going to get you set up on the
table and we're going to do that citizen
medicine okay I'm gonna pull this out
under your legs most patients are
partially awake during the procedures
they get IV medication for pain and
anxiety the lights are dimmed they're
soothing music it actually feels a lot
like a childbirth the medical gown your
bare legs and stirrups and a person next
to you saying you can do this
breathe
that's Brandy she's one of the staffers
her job is to monitor vital signs but it
is also to hold the patient's hand and
talk her through this whether it's a
birth or an abortion it is often women
guiding other women you're going to hear
this machine turn on now okay makes a
loud noise
[Music]
anything
keep breathing Brandi tells her over and
over I can't the patient says at one
point when the cramps get painful yes
you can Brandi tells her you're doing it
and then within just a couple of minutes
it's over
[Music]
let's take some deep breaths for me
[Music]
you did it hmm
thank you guys so much
[Music]
you're fine
I
really went back and forth over whether
to play that on the show or not because
it's truly nauseating and I bet that
I bet that many of you are sick to your
stomach hearing it
and it's not because you haven't it's
not because you haven't seen violence
before or heard violence or probably
seen or heard people die on video I mean
we see crime videos we've seen seen
videos from war
real video I'm not talking about
Hollywood or anything like that you've
seen news footage from Wars you've
you've seen crime videos you've probably
seen or heard people die before there's
something especially nauseating about
this even compared to crime videos or
war videos
because it's a mother doing it and the
way the way that this NPR host
introduces it she says
you know it's in many ways this
procedure is a lot like giving birth
yeah it is because you are giving birth
it's just instead of giving birth to a
living baby to nurture this baby and
care for this baby as you ought to do
you're giving birth to a baby that
you've
likely already killed in the womb
and then you're giving birth to it to
throw them away in the trash
so it's
it's just it's just nauseating
and
someone wrote in when this story was
going viral the reason I ended up
deciding that we should play it on the
air is because this was this was on
National Public Radio
this was
as
public as it could possibly be public in
the sense that yes it was aired in on a
mainstream platform but public in that
our political system paid for it you
paid for for this to to Air and I
believe the reason that NPR chose to do
it because NPR is very far left and why
we funded I have no idea but the reason
they chose to do it is because they
think that it's going to destigmatize
and demystify abortion well yes it will
demystify abortion because it will get
rid of the euphemisms that people always
use Reproductive Rights Women's Health
Care all these euphemisms that are
actually are deceptive that actually not
not only do they sugarcoat the procedure
but they they invert it they say it's
it's reproductive it's not it's the
opposite of reproductive they say it's
Healthcare it's not Healthcare it's
murder and and so it demystifies it but
I don't think it destigmatizes it I
think it it
really demonstrates to people why there
is a stigma around abortion there's a
stigma around abortion because it's the
murder of a child
and so I think it completely backfires
and I think it's actually important to
amplify this for for people to see
they're into here to hear the reality of
it
some mouthy lib that I saw on social
media when I posted this along with
other people
said oh you're so sickened by this what
you've never seen video of a school
shooting and I thought first of all no I
never have seen video of a school
shooting I don't I don't know that
anyone has are there videos of the
school shootings I don't think so but
furthermore even if such a thing existed
this would be worse
because
killing is a fact of life this is a
fallen world and it's a sin that just
exists there is murder in the world and
there's war and there's just regular
Street murder and there's even there's
even murder in high schools and there's
even murder of poor little children and
all these things
but it's even worse when the murderer is
the mother it's so much more perverse I
mean this was Mother Teresa's speech to
the U.N she said the the biggest problem
in the world today the the cause of of
political evils more so than any other
cause
is abortion because if a mother can kill
her own child then there's nothing that
that anyone won't do
absolutely horrifying stuff
and in the face of this horrifying stuff
is it any wonder that people are turning
away from the Democrats that NPR audio
that was their election strategy
because they couldn't run on anything
else they were running on that
and why is it not working because when
the reality of what the Democrats want
what the libs want is presented to
people they see that it's horrifying
once you get past all the euphemisms and
all the merely math to BS language you
just what you hear is the the vacuum
turn on
and you you say wow I we can't have that
and and this is
even people who were so personally
offended by Donald Trump even the the
squishes and the moderates and the Never
Trump conservatives and whatever all of
these people who endorsed Joe Biden
you're seeing them move away now
forget about the libs the kind of
moderate Libs like Bill Maher or Joe
Rogan or Elon Musk who you've seen for
much move much more to the right but
even someone like George Will who was a
major conservative writer and then he
went full-on never Trump and he endorsed
Joe Biden and he voted for Joe Biden
well George Will has even come out it's
one of the most anti-trump voices in the
country and he just came out and he said
for the good of the country Biden and
Harris should bow out of the 2024
election even the people who were who
made such a show of endorsing Joe Biden
or having buyer's remorse the collective
leftist meltdown that is going to occur
on Election night next week
I think it's going to be glorious unless
some water pipes break unless some votes
come in and Philly at three in the
morning
I think truly nothing could match it
will say a close second
is everything that we're rolling out
here at Daily wire plus episode two of
Jordan Peterson's new series on marriage
is out
this episode is all about negotiating or
should I say learning the proper way to
negotiate also available now is Candace
owens's brand new episode of her show
taboo featuring special guest and
multi-platinum selling musician Mia you
will hear her rise to fame and how she
was canceled for speaking out about
vaccine mandates among other topics then
there's Ben Shapiro Sunday special which
is releasing the Sunday Ben sat down
with Tennessee governor Bill Lee to chat
about school choice fighting through
coveted policies and more last step
daily wire plus has just released the
documentary film my dinner with Trump
this is a behind the curtain look at the
former president and his closest
advisors as they have a dinner together
at his private club at Bedminster if
you're not a member there's never been a
better time to join go to dailywire.com
Knowles to become a member today
George Will has come back around he left
the GOP because he hates Trump so much
he endorsed Joe Biden because he hates
Trump so much and he says for the good
of the country Biden and Harris should
bow out of the 2024
uh election
he says Joe Biden should not seek
another term Democrat should promptly
face that fact and this one and Everest
of evidence shows the vice president
Harris's starkly unqualified to be
considered as his successor
and then he goes through the Litany of
terrible things that Biden has done I'm
glad he has buyer's remorse I'm glad he
realizes
albeit late that he made a mistake I'm
not sure that George Will would say I
was wrong to vote for him in 2020 but
he's effectively saying that when he
says that Biden and Harris are not fit
to be president neither of them
I prefer people that got it right the
first time
I'm all for grace for the people who get
things wrong and then way after the fact
they say oh actually you know
uh maybe you guys weren't weren't
totally wrong but when I think of the
moral preening that we heard from people
like George Will whose writing I've
enjoyed for much of my life but the the
preening the the constant haranguing of
those allegedly unprincipled
conservatives who voted for Trump
certainly in 2016 we heard this and then
in 2020 we heard it too and and now they
come around and they say wow gosh golly
look at this Joe Biden has completely
destroyed the world and Kamala Harris is
also not fit to be president and I think
yeah
yeah you're right we were totally right
man and you were totally wrong and it
wasn't just that it was an honest
disagreement you harangued us and you
called us a moral and you called us
stupid and you called us unprincipled
and all the rest of it and we were right
and you were wrong
and this is just how it goes with
especially political punditry it's it's
kind of like sports punditry too it's
just these guys go on TV and they get
everything wrong every single day and
all their predictions turn out to be
bogus and then they're invited back the
next day for some reason
this is why I can't wear my Nostradamus
hat too much is because if I if I keep
showing that my predictions are more
often correct then I'm going to lose my
job because you're not allowed to have
correct predictions and be a political
pundit you're not you're not allowed to
be in politics if your predictions are
right okay and but it just
it can be very frustrating
for those of us there are many people
listening who were right about Trump
from the beginning and they faced all
sorts of abuse because
because we were right and the other guys
were wrong or who were right about covid
from the beginning and we faced all
sorts of abuse and we were called idiots
and we were called murderers and we were
called uneducated and whatever and we
were right and they were totally wrong
on every aspect of covet on the origin
of covid on the masks on the distancing
on the vaccines on everything we were
right and and those people were wrong
and it's
the the lesson to take from this is not
I think one of vendettas and Vengeance
and you know even casting George Will
into the outer Darkness where there's
wailing and gnashing of teeth I'm all
for bringing people back in if they if
they come back and they even tacitly
admit okay you were right I was wrong
I'm back on the team now I welcome
people back onto the team but it is a
lesson for for all of us
when we're listening to voices and when
we're looking for people to read and
listen to on on what's going on in
politics it's good to take note of who
got things right and who got things
wrong I'll probably still read George
will sometimes because he's a good
writer his prose is just very good but
his political perception is not what it
once was it's totally totally off
because these people allowed themselves
to be driven Crazy by their personal and
irrational hatred of Donald Trump
it also when people spend too much time
in the Beltway and too much time in the
fancy circles and they just get divorced
from reality that's just what happens
there was an amazing divorce from
reality we saw uh the United Nations
just uh tweeted out uh this was from U.N
women
a big warning about journalists being
killed and they here's the statistic
they say of all journalists killed in
2021 11 were women in 2020 this was six
percent
an international day to end impunity for
crimes against journalists let us say
out loud stop targeting women
journalists hashtag protect journalists
let me I'm going to look at those
numbers again of all the journalists
killed 11 percent are women stop
targeting women so if 11 what's 100
minus 11 that's 80. 89 of the
journalists killed are men 11 of the
journalists killed are women
would you would you say that constitutes
a targeting of women
would seem to constitute a targeting of
men
or just journalists generally they
probably weren't paying much attention
to the sex at all
targeting women well what this tells you
is
a fact of our culture which we've talked
about for a while and it's just becoming
clearer every single day
men can never be the victim unless
they've got something that makes them
transgressive or subversive or otherwise
different from the norm so if they're
gay or trans transvest diets or
something like that then they can get
some points and some sympathy but but
men who are just regular old men who
behave like men who are just normal they
can never be the victim according to our
culture's narrative in the same way that
white people can never be the victim
everything white people do is wrong if
white people
eat taco bowls on Cinco de Mayo that's
cultural appropriation if white people
don't eat taco bowls on Cinco de Mayo
that's culturally racial there's nothing
they can do that's right if men
assert themselves they're toxic if men
don't assert themselves they're in cells
there's nothing they can they're always
terrible and it doesn't matter if men
die younger it doesn't matter if men in
this in this case if this statistic are
being disproportionately killed you know
overwhelmed they're constitute almost
every journalist that's killed almost is
a man 89 doesn't matter their pain is
not only doesn't matter but it's
something to mock it's something
to laugh at and
we we can yell until we're blue in the
face about the hypocrisy but the
takeaway from it is the the
liberal establishment just hates men and
hates white people and and
broadly speaking hates conservatives and
even though this is not a fair
conflation they conflate all three of
those things
and so you're never you're never going
to get really anywhere by pointing out
the hypocrisy you might be able to
persuade some people in the middle or
some people who are on the fence or you
might be able to you know encourage
conservatives to see this thing more
clearly that's what we're trying to do
now but you're never going to convince
the libs to you'll say now you guys
you're being hypocritical you're not
being nice to the men or the white
people or the they don't care they don't
like us okay they don't like us they
don't consider us legitimate
participants in our democracy that's why
when the Republicans win the Democrats
reject the election results because they
don't consider us legitimate
participants in our sacred democracy and
when the libs win now we don't really
buy those results because the libs rig
the elections and brag about it the libs
keep telling us everywhere they say it's
going to take days it's probably going
to take weeks to count all the votes and
my question is why are the Democrats so
confident that it's going to take days
and weeks to count the votes isn't there
a chance that we know the results on
Election night like we did for all of
American History until five minutes ago
and until the Trump Administration when
the libs lost their minds isn't there a
chance that we know the results no
they're so confident why is that why is
it that they're so confident because
they're they have a plan in place to try
to rig things now the Red Wave might be
so massive that it just doesn't matter
but make no mistake the libs believe
they are totally justified in doing
anything illegal immoral to stop
Republicans from winning because they
believe as Michael Bachelor said
democracy as Joe Biden said democracy is
on the ballot
and that if they lose the whole country
is going to go to pot and they're we're
going to ship journalists and historians
to the gulag and we're going to we're
going to arrest and murder their
children that's what they're saying
that's what they're saying on TV they
will do anything to stop that our
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk head
on over to puretalk.com select a plan
enter promo code Knowles to get 50 off
your first month
take it away with the voicemail bag
hello and Nostradamus first of all
greetings from Sydney Australia my
question is uh there's this quote that
has been incorrectly attributed to
Voltaire the quote is if you want to
know who controls you look at who you
are not allowed to criticize now the
quote belongs to a white supremacist
called Kevin Strom however there's quite
a lot of Truth in it which is why I
think it is often attributed to Voltaire
and my question is is it possible for an
evil man or an evil woman to say
something or have an idea that from our
more righteous Source will be true or
righteous
that's it once again take care hope to
see you in Australia one day thanks
heaps
yeah of course of course that's possible
it's funny I have seen that quote going
around to the internet and it it's a
reminder that whenever you see a quote
on the internet especially one that is
attributed to a prominent figure like
Voltaire or Ben Franklin or Ronald
Reagan or Winston Churchill or Abraham
Lincoln uh just assume it's a false
attribution you have to Google it
yourself and you have to go down and
find a legitimate citation otherwise I
think it's very safe to assume the quote
is not legit and so this one is
particularly embarrassing these people
are posting this around because the
quote seems true it has the Ring of
truth to it they post it around and most
people don't even know who Voltaire is
but they know that he's like a fancy
person that educated people quote and so
they attribute it and then it turns out
it's this Neo-Nazi criminal guy so
that's that's very embarrassing but of
course bad people can say true things
even a stopped clock is right twice a
day I mean Karl Marx said a lot of true
things he was an evil man who who had
extremely perverse ideas and was
probably obsessed or possessed by demons
but he yeah he made some astute
observations about politics so did Lenin
and Stalin okay you know I mean this
this gets to that problem of in politics
you know everyone I don't like is Hitler
and so you'll say oh you know I Donald
Trump just drank some water Hitler drank
water too you know who else drank water
and you think okay yeah not
not every single thing that bad people
say or do is wrong or evil okay life is
a little more complicated than that but
my only other point on on the that quote
which the quote has certainly has the
Ring of truth to it so that's why people
are quoting it across the political
Spectrum
you also shouldn't quote Voltaire
Voltaire was a very bad guy who had very
stupid ideas so you should yeah I guess
you shouldn't quote neo-nazis but also
it's you also shouldn't quote Voltaire
okay you should quote good smart
virtuous people not derelicts like like
Voltaire okay next question
Michael Knowles your number one fan in
the world coming to you right now asking
for your advice I'm a pretty traditional
guy and I believe that the husband
should have the final say in most things
in a marriage but my wife brings up an
interesting point when it comes to
naming your children who should have the
final word there because that to me does
seem like a category that would fall
more under motherly Instinct than
fatherly Instinct and my wife also
argues she's the one who has to carry
the baby for nine months and push it out
so if there is a disagreement she should
be the one who gets the final word so
I'm just wondering what you think about
this is this something that husbands
should stand up and fight for or is this
one that the ladies can take thanks
great question I'm so pleased to hear
from my number one fan it's a very
important question
but your instinct is totally wrong
the husband should have the final say in
everything because the husband is the
head of household
and the husband does not get the final
say because you know he works extra hard
the mothers work extremely hard wives
work extremely hard
many ways in many cases they work harder
than the husband that's not
the reason the man has the final say is
because he is the head of household that
is what you are signing on to when
you get married
at least traditionally these days I
guess people get married and they have
like you know polygamous five sums and
then they get divorced five minutes
later but in the traditional
understanding of marriage that's that's
the way that it that it is
the husband is the head of the household
not because of the individual Merit of
the husband but because that's what
marriage is the husband has the final
say and is that because he's the head of
household so
either the husband has the final say on
everything
or he doesn't have the final say
or he isn't the head of the household
it's a it is an All or Nothing thing now
when I say the husband has the final say
I just I I'm not saying he's going to
rule like some Tyrant or anything like
that
on
maybe the majority of decisions is
particularly pertaining to the family or
the the household
the what the woman wants she's probably
gonna get
and the head of household just like the
head of a company just like that of a
country will delegate
most things but ultimately if the man is
to be the head of his household if the
man is to be
the head of his wife is Christ as the
head of the church then he's got to have
the final say that's just that by
definition
and so have conversations with your wife
you know go back and forth don't pick
some stupid name for your kid but you
know act like a man what's the matter
with you okay next question
hey Michael my name is John I'm a
student at Marquette University and a
resident of Illinois as such I can vote
in either of the Senate races and I'm
hoping that you can help me decide which
would be more efficacious in the coming
elections the Wisconsin polls are very
close though Johnson seems to be pulling
ahead whereas in Illinois Kathy salvey
astonished the Catholic non-squishy
Republican mom a friend of my family's
and ostensibly the best chance
Republicans have had in decades is down
in the polls by around 11 points though
there have only been a few polls since
the race seems to be obviously one for
Tammy Duckworth already my friends
working in the salvi campaign think that
the polls are vastly under counting
Kathy's support and are hoping to ride
the Red Wave but I am skeptical given
the gap which race would you suggest
that I vote in and why thank you so much
for all you do and hopefully I can tempt
you back to Wisconsin with a cigar and a
glass of whiskey upon arrival
that sounds great I'll look forward to
that next time I'm in Wisconsin in terms
of the race I'd probably
I'd probably vote in Wisconsin
and I'd probably vote for Johnson not
not because I think Ron Johnson is the
most right-wing member of the Senate and
not because I have any you know
particular affection for Wisconsin over
any other state I I like Wisconsin a lot
there's a good cigar bar in Milwaukee
but just because that's the tight race
and you mentioned that that it's a red
wave year and you're friends with the
candidate in Illinois and the people on
her campaign say you know look the polls
are under under Counting maybe the polls
are
are the polls under counting though and
underestimating her by 11 points
maybe the polls are underestimating her
by Five Points 6.7 points
I'm not saying it's impossible that she
wins she sounds great I haven't looked
into the race I hope she wins
but
when you've got a real nail biter of a
race as we could be seeing what the race
in Wisconsin right now is
five points or within five points so I
just prudentially I'd probably vote up
there I guess politics I follow that
Buckley rule you you vote for the most
right viable candidate and politics is
not about
Perfection exactly and it's not about
idealism exactly you've got you've got
to deal with political realities and on
a nail biter I'd probably I'd probably
vote in the nail biter race if you have
the choice to vote in either all right
next voicemail by question
hey Michael I had a question about
pursuing a good career for young people
um it seems to me that my older friends
and my peers have different perspectives
on this
um this is kind of oversimplifying it
but I would say that the older
generation seem to have a perspective
about work that it's just your
responsibility and you have to do it and
you know yeah chasing your dreams is
okay but ultimately you just have to do
what's going to put food on the table
and the younger Generations seem to have
more of an intense focus on finding your
true passion and what you're calling is
and I think there's some crossover but
uh what would be your advice to someone
who's young who's trying to figure out
where they fit in their career because
I'm finding it really difficult to find
what my sweet spot is and it seems like
a lot of employers nowadays want to know
what that is
um and you know I'm obviously very
passionate about being able to put food
on the table but there's also some truth
in that you can probably find a much
easier path to success if you're in work
that you love and work that you're good
at and so I'd just love to hear your
perspective on this thanks so much love
the show
thank you I don't recommend desperately
chasing your dreams I think that's a bad
idea
but I do recommend strategically and
methodically and prudentially pursuing
your dreams
it's it's not just follow your dreams or
settle for some job that you hate that
will give you a steady paycheck
there is another option there too which
is you can apply rigor and reality and
logic and Prudence to the pursuit of
your dreams as well
I have a fake job
in the sense that if you just look at
the hours that I work I I work all the
time I work a lot I am
there are very few hours where I'm not
doing something that somehow relates to
my job for most of the week
but I feel like I am never working
or at least very rarely working because
I love what I do because I have a fake
job because I get to go and speak about
the things that I care about and write
essays and books about the things that I
care about and talk to you guys on the
show and get to have some influence in
politics on things that I want to so and
all of that
fortunately relates to my job I've
worked plenty of other just pay the
bills jobs
and and as I have pursued my dreams I've
gone down bad paths on my dreams and had
to turn around and I've met certain dead
ends and then I've kind of zigzagged and
so there's all of that and now I've
worked different jobs to kind of pay the
bills and keep a roof over my head while
I was doing that
it would be a it would be a mistake to
throw off all of your responsibilities
to just chase some pipe dream that very
likely will not be good for you very
often the things that we think our
dreams are are very are would ultimately
be sort of harmful for us and God
generally has better plans for us than
we have for ourselves because he is
omniscious and omni-benevolent and we
are
fallen and corrupt and have little
pea-sized brains uh so it's it's good
you you ought to have a sense of where
you want to go you ought to have
ambition you ought to really apply some
rigor to that thought
and you want to pursue it and you ought
to do the right thing and you ought to
not compromise morally
and if you can do all that while meeting
your obligations to your family to your
community to your God and if you can do
all of that while meeting your moral
obligations as well and well
you know acting with virtue then I think
that's great
I'm not you know a lot of conservatives
on this question let's say give up your
dreams and just work some job that you
hate that gives you a paycheck I don't
think that's true
I didn't take that advice and I'm glad I
didn't
just like you'll often hear conservative
say you forget about you should never go
to college and if you do go to college
you should never study anything that has
anything to do with culture or
Humanities you should just study
engineering or something I don't think
that's true I didn't follow that advice
and no if you if you have an inclination
toward philosophy or history or
literature or culture and you have any
inclination or aptitude and aptitude for
it at all then yeah you absolutely
should pursue that
but don't just go take out you know half
a million dollars in debt and have no
plan for what you're going to do after
but absolutely you can do that come on
if we're I don't think the conservatives
are the political party of kill all of
your dreams don't think of anything
higher than just putting a slab of beef
on the table no of course not that's the
what the materialists say that's what
the libs say conservatives understand
that there is much more to life and that
if we want to have a thriving family and
thriving communities and we want and and
we want to pursue the purpose that God
has for us that we do need to have
higher ideals and we do need to have a
broader view of life than just consuming
stuff
all right there's more to get to I've
got the regular old written mail bags
I'm going to get to a few of those in
the member block and then it is fake
headline Friday so I will need your help
Ben Davies has given me
four real headlines one fake headline
he's going to test my ability to
understand our always absurd news cycle
to parse fact from fiction the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign